grant cardone is a popular real estate
investor on YouTube who often shows off
his 20 million dollar condo his luxury
cars and of course his brand-new 55
Minotaur jet as inspiration
he always preaches about the power of
real estate and leverage and Loki and
his lifestyle he has certainly paid off
for him but this brings up the question
how much does grant cardone actually
make
[Music]
[Applause]
well starting off Grant Cardone is a CEO
of Cardone enterprises which is
basically an umbrella company for five
sub companies these companies include
Cardone training technologies card on
university card on acquisitions card on
capital and grant cardone TV network as
2017 each of these companies have
revenue exceeding 100 million dollars
but the exact figures are unknown as
these are private companies however this
does tell us that as total annual
revenue is well over 500 million dollars
upwards of 1 billion dollars considering
this let's place as annual revenue at
750 million dollars but how much of this
is actually profit while many of Grants
businesses are high cashflow businesses
with very low operational expenses for
example Cardone University and Cardone
training technologies are selling
information so they don't need to invest
in manufacturing plans materials factory
workers research and development and so
on and so forth like a traditional
business would they simply need to
develop a program advertise it and sell
it now I am NOT saying that's easy by
any means but evidently it does need
much less cash ruin and has high profit
margins generally such businesses can
have net profit margins as highest 90%
when done individually but in Grant's
case he has hundreds of employees to pay
large venues to rent and international
travel expenses as a result his net
income margin is nowhere near this
amount despite this his margins should
still be quite high at 20 or 40 percent
let's conservatively placed these two
businesses at 30 percent net income the
same however cannot be said for his real
estate businesses which include Carter
on capital and Cardone acquisitions real
estate is a great investment as it is
quite passive but it is a cash intensive
business of course real estate
enthusiasts like meet Kevin would
strongly advocate that you don't need
much cash in hand to invest in real
estate and this is true you can get
Investment Partners loans crowdfunding
there's plenty of ways to buy real
estate without funding the cost
but even with the best West deals on a
market you cannot net profit anywhere
near 30 percent consistently year after
year like grants information on
businesses furthermore such numbers are
even harder to achieve with larger
properties with hundreds of units like
grant buys as a result grants net income
Mohnish real estate businesses are
likely closer to 10 percent
this would include cash flow small West
deals equity growth and appreciation and
that leaves a grant cardone TV this is
again an informational business but the
difference between this and Cardone
university is that they don't charge
several horn dollars per customer on top
of this there are much more recurring
costs they have to pay editors cameramen
audio guys and much more every single
episode they make it's not like a course
where you make a once updated here and
there and continually get revenue
furthermore most of the content on Grant
Cardone TV is free and the only revenue
sources ad revenue and merchandise sales
as a result for Grant Cardone TV there
is much less revenue coming in and much
more expenses in comparison to grants
other informational products TV networks
generally have profit margins of 10 to
15 percent for instance Fox had a net
profit margin of 15% and CBS had a net
profit margin of 11 point 8 m % in the
last quarter of 2019 of course grant
doesn't have nearly as many expenses as
these giants as his productions
proportionally cost much less and he
doesn't have to deal with TV providers
and what not so let's put Grant Cardone
TV at a 15 percent net profit margin
considering this Cardone Enterprises has
an overall net profit margin of about 20
percent as the five businesses are
relatively equal in terms of revenue if
anything Cardone crane technologies is
the biggest of the five and has one of
the highest profit margin in the group
so this should pull the net profit
margin of Carter Enterprises above 20
percent even conservatively with revenue
of seven hundred and fifteen million
dollars kourin enterprises should
generate 150 million dollars in net
profit per year but grant doesn't get
all of this money
he doesn't own all the company because
if he did his net worth would be a lot
higher in the interview with Omar about
three years ago
grant claimed that net worth is five
hundred and forty million dollars well
with some more accurate figure 545 look
at it every day
all these revery numbers are also about
two years old so we'll assume that when
these revenue figures were taken his net
worth was 540 million dollars let's also
say that 40 million of this or a little
less than 10 percent is not invest in
carton enterprises with 150 million
dollars in profit kourin enterprises
would be worth two point four seven five
billion dollars on average this is
assuming that Cardone Enterprises is
valued using the average price to
earnings ratio of sixteen point five
this would mean that Grant Cardone
owns about 20 percent of car owned
enterprises meaning agus net income two
to three years ago was about thirty nine
dollars conservatively the number was
probably closer to 50 million dollars
and up to 70 million dollars using lower
p/e ratios and less conservative
earnings estimates over the past few
years Grant Cardone has seen exponential
growth in many of his businesses such as
Cardone capital as crowdfunding efforts
have skyrocketed in fact Cardone capital
assets under management have nearly
doubled in just the past year from eight
hundred ninety million at the start of
2019 to 1.7 billion dollars today
similarly his following on YouTube has
over quadrupled over the past three
years this means that more people are
buying his courses more people are
investing in Cardone capital and more
people are attending a sales conferences
as a result it's likely that the net
income for Cardone Enterprises is now
well over double what it was a few years
ago this would mean that grant cardone
now makes about 100 million dollars a
year plus or minus 20 million do you
guys agree major comment down below also
if you guys thought this video provided
a good analysis of Grasse income then
make sure to drop a like and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari
guys on the next one
[Music]